coming up next I know now when certain
guys based on they don't mean it he went
to jail yeah but free yourself for what
um but he wasn't a bad guy no I feel
like when you love people and when
people love you it's a very selfish kind
of thing yeah I was 14.
and he was 19. I was 16 and he was 20
and he was already a father
he was I was 14 he was 16. so we were
still a little better yeah what is it
with this oh honestly what do you guys
do in England I thought he was the most
handsome guy that I'd ever seen in my
life and I was super flattered that he
was talking to me I mean as a young
woman you have so much Choice like
there's so many men in the friend zone
are very stable but we never pick up
when you were interested in somebody you
you all logic goes out of the window
I know we have a mixed crowd when it
comes to age so who knows who Pamela
Anderson and Tommy Lee yeah yeah you
know I don't follow social okay
so Pamela Anderson's huge okay so Pamela
Anderson is an actress um Tommy Lee is a
rock star for those of you that don't
know and
um they I was researching them for this
show and they've had just like an
on-again off-again relationship sense
let me see it says
1994. so they
um got married after four days of
knowing each other yeah
um after they got married in Cancun
Mexico
and literally they were just on again
off again they also had a sex tape that
was released during
um when they were together
they had two sons
and he also was
arrested for abuse
um and she still actually got he went to
jail for it and she actually still got
back with him after
and then again on again off again on
again off again until now they're not
together they've separated and he's
married to someone else and she's single
now the reason that I bring this up is
because
recently she has been doing a
documentary and in the documentary she
said
that she texted at 55 she hasn't been
with him for five years she texted Tommy
Lee that he is her one true love
while he's married to someone else
damn so
um my question for the panel was have
you ever had an ex that was incredibly
hard to get over
and what made him so hard to get over
that one for me I would say
it was really like my first kind of love
so I was at a young age I think I was
like 18 at the time when I got with him
so I feel like when you're at that age
especially us women being so emotional I
just felt really attached to him and
even though I'd see him doing a lot I
feel like I'd always want to run back to
him
everything was there he just knew the
right word to kind of say and I feel
like oh I was too good at getting
something how long were you on again off
again with him so from 18 to one from 18
until I was turning 20. so like nearly
three years no I'm sorry nearly two
years okay but that one was very serious
we kept going back
um
we initially started talking in like
2019 and then by the end of
um 2021 that's when we called it quits
but during that stage during that um
that time period we got together about
three times on breakup three times so
yeah and would you say he was a nice guy
or a bad boy Looking Back Now definitely
a bad guy a bad boy bad guy bad guy yeah
what makes you say that just like
obviously the age I am now in the
maturity I have looking back there's a
lot of things that he used to do like
he'll be very good with his words I know
now when certain guys say stuff they
don't mean it but back then it's very
easy to get sucked in like I said before
and he just he used to always know the
right words to say which can be a good
trait sometimes but in relationships
especially as a guy
and what made it so hard to leave just
because he knew the right things to say
he was telling you a dream pretty much
and you know it's that popular it was
popular for me because obviously that
was like my first real proper like
relationship like we moved in together
and everything so it was very serious
and obviously at that age as well I'm
thinking like this is some fairy tale
going on but realizing now and looking
back at it now I wouldn't have done so
many things that I did do and listened
to him the way that I did if that makes
sense okay
um you want to go next yeah um I feel
like my the love that I had um is kind
of different to yours in the sense that
a man wasn't a bad guy
um we both really cared about each other
and it was whereas kind of on and off
for some time but he went in jail and
for like three years he went to jail
yeah like three years for one
um but he wasn't a bad guy no okay okay
so the reason why we always want to see
the good and the drugs
a lot of times certain situations it's a
cop-out answer sometimes to say oh
you're not a situation things like that
but generally for this guy like
the way that um he was brought up from
very very young was was not good and it
kind of like that was the path that was
predestined for him but then he's kind
of like got out of it now and I'm like
we're good and everything but
for me it was very difficult to get over
him when he came out of jail
um we wanted to get back together but I
was like you know what you have to
change yourself everything like this
first and he took a year to do it and by
that time
um I was like we're not gonna get back
together but I was still very much in
love with him but I had to just realize
that the amount that I loved him and the
amount that I love myself I'm very
solid on what I want and what I do not
want from a man and um he had a child as
well and in that time the year that he
took to change I realized that I do not
want to be with someone who already has
a child because I'm selfish I want to be
first for a little bit of the
relationship at least
but um did he change in that year yeah
he did the total 160. so he he was a bit
like more of a bad guy before and then
he like changed into more of a nice guy
he was I mean he was in jail we can't he
was he he was always a nice guy he's
very good got a beautiful heart but I
just feel like he saw that there was
another way to live life rather than the
one that he had been stuck in for that
time
um it just was a thing where I realized
that as much as I love him and as much
as he loves me and all these kind of
things like there's a greater kind of
love like I feel like when you love
people and when people love you it's a
very selfish kind of thing because it's
like I love you I want I want you to be
with me and we're going to make it work
and what I want but I was just like you
know what for the best for what I want
and what you want you can't just keep on
going down this path what what made him
different than other guys that made it
hard for for you to get over him
everyone says that they want honesty I
had this whole time we're talking about
it earlier but he was genuinely very
honest if he did something bad he did
something good like I had a lot of
issues of Trust And even if he did
something bad he was honest and it kind
of made me accept that you know what
even if I might feel like people are
down the wrong road and I have a
stereotype of roadmen that they're that
they're dishonest and that they like to
use words because men know that women
want to hear certain things right and I
feel like men use that to manipulate
women and he showed me that you know
what someone can go be in that lifestyle
want better for themselves and not
manipulate you of words they could just
tell you the truth and if you don't
accept it you don't accept it and then
you have to sort out what you're going
to do from there on so you like that he
told you what it was exactly yes and
that's what made him different you feel
like other guys told you what you wanted
to hear where he told you the truth and
yes and also another thing which I think
a lot of men nowadays really struggle
with is being assertive in a respectful
way like he would not allow me like I
can be a bit I think everyone can be a
bit um push the buttons of it sometimes
you know push the boundaries and stuff
but he always let me know this is not
how it's going to be do not continue
this behavior and I respected that
because he knew the right way to do it
and a lot of men do not know how to do
that nowadays they get angry or they
don't know how to express themselves or
they um blame you and yeah this is just
another one okay okay and what about you
right okay so when I
um was going out with my ex I was very
young compared to him so how old are you
how old was he
okay
I just steal it
yeah I was 14.
and he was 19.
sorry shot caller everyone yeah but he
actually did ask permission from my mom
and dad because he was like I really
like your daughter
and he was he wasn't like a creep he
wasn't giving creep okay he was giving
like
gentlemen actually and he was very kind
and sweet but it was also long distance
as well so he was living in Holland and
I was living here but he would get like
um I think it was like a 12-hour coach
every two weeks to come and see me and
he was working like two jobs as well at
like 19 years of age
um but I think from that
because I was so young he was my first
everything as well like first
well you know what I mean like first
everything and so I think that's what
kept the attachment for so long but how
long were you with him three years three
years yeah but
I think because I was so young I think I
was just so excited that like an older
boy had liked me really and when I look
back on it now at 21 years of age I'm
thinking
I don't think that's too right if one of
my friends would come to me and say I
like a 15 year old would you think why
did your parents allow that because they
saw how he was because he was a nice
yeah he was a good dude I was literally
begging them as well like if your
daughter's growing like I love him you
know what I mean what can you do right
um
but I think the attachment was is
because I was so young and I think I was
with him for that long
because I was so young and also didn't
really know what I want so you you would
have said he was a good guy though yeah
I'm not a bad boy good boy no he wasn't
a bad guy at all but I'm in a
relationship now
um and it what made him different was
that you were young it was your first
like guy that you were with yeah okay
yeah literally but um I look on it
I look on it now as in it was an okay
experience
but we also broke up in between as well
and that's I think
because I was so young
I like Miss the
the love and like the kind of like he
kind of led the way through everything
so I think that's why I went back but I
actually broke up with him because I was
bored you broke up with him because you
were boring I broke up with him like
three times just because you were bored
because like one because I was bored
because we what do we have in common
really what do you haven't come on with
a 14 year old and 19 like we are
actually in different Paths of life and
then
he was long distance as well and
it's just I was growing up and I was
starting to like other things and I was
starting to
actually know what my type was maybe you
know so yeah that's that's the reason
why I think I kept on going back because
of the age okay but yeah what about you
yeah I can kind of relate to some of
what you're saying there because my
first relationship I was 16 and he was
20 and he was already a father
um and again my mum did not want me to
date this guy she would literally pin me
down uh to stop me what was wrong with
them the fact that he had a child and he
was 20 right okay yeah yeah so yeah it
was like that's not what you want for
your 16 year old daughter
um but yeah I fell head over heels in
love with him
um I moved out of home when I was 17.
got my own place he moved in with me so
we were having a very adult relationship
from the age of 17.
um I did end up breaking up with him
because actually what was interesting
was I ended up taking on quite a
masculine role in that relationship I
started earning very well and he wasn't
and I was then paying everything and it
was I lost respect for him to be honest
um and I kind of made it known it kind
of came out as quite an outburst one day
and I was like you know don't feel
embarrassed about the fact that every
time we go to the movies I'm getting my
purse out and every time we get you know
and all this
so he and how old were you did you say
um so at that point when I broke up with
him I was getting on for 19. okay so
you're with him for three years yeah
yeah
um broke up with him um but I loved him
you know I really loved him he
retaliated when I bought that to
Ascension by throwing furniture around
so I was like right you're out you know
that was that he was a bad boy too well
it actually wasn't but he was so ashamed
that it was like he reacted by just
throwing a Jaws like punching the wall
but I'd never seen that side of him
before Oh okay he was soft as a kitten
up until that point and then you said I
pay I pay for all our dates like you you
yelled at him and then he started
punching the wall yeah but but in three
years I'd never seen that side of him
okay but at that point I was like pack
your bags you're gone right yeah he had
to kick him to the curse he had to go he
had to go right but then when he moved
on and got into another relationship I
then started to feel like actually maybe
I still love him and wanted to be with
him so it was almost like when he when
someone else wanted him I wanted him
back you know and then it actually took
a while for me to get over him which was
strange
um wait so you were you were good you
were moved on then you found out he was
dating someone else and you you wanted
him back yeah he wanted me back did you
get him back or no
um no so he he actually was trying to
get me back for a period of time I
didn't want to know but then the moment
he got with somebody else it was a bit
of a toxic trait in me you know I then
wanted him back
um and that that time it was too late
because he then moved on moved him moved
in with someone else and it actually did
take me a long time because I sort of
thought oh you know maybe he is my my
one true love you know
um he made a mistake but he's still a
good guy and I still love him so it did
take me a while to get over that one I
think because it was that first
significant relationship
what about you interesting okay so mine
is a little bit chaotic I guess
um my ex-partner and the father of my
children
um I met him when I was 14 years old
no how old was he he was I was 14 he was
16. so we were still a little better
yeah what is it with this oh honestly
what are you guys doing England
it was a bit grooy
Yeah so um so he was like he was my
first ever boyfriend and when I met him
I remember this I was at school and I
met him he came and chatted me up at the
bus stop after school with his friends
um and I thought he was the most
handsome guy that I'd ever seen in my
life and I was super flattered that he
was talking to me
um so we dated I say we dated we're in a
little bit of a relationship for maybe
like a year
um and then he broke up with me
and I was just I was heartbroken I think
at that time I really convinced myself
that I loved him and that I was mature
enough to know what love was and my
friends and my family were like no he's
not for you he's not they were obviously
seeing something that I didn't see
because you're in that bubble of being
in love and this juvenile sense of he's
my everything like at 14 I don't think
you can know what your everything is
um so we we were together first kind of
intimate experience and things like that
and I think that I put that uh I held
that to quite and you know on quite a
pedal stall that I was intimate with
somebody for the first time and so This
Must Be Love and we're going to be
together forever
um we our relationship came to an end
when we was I don't know I think maybe
like a year later I was about 15.
um and I saw other people and things
like that but he would always contact me
so it will be like we wouldn't speak for
maybe like six months or something I'd
change my number and then I'd randomly
bump into him in the street which just
kept fueling this sense in my mind of oh
my God we're clearly meant to be
together when did the kid come and she
said he was the father yeah when did the
kid come in so we got back together
um I would say again sort of in line
with that whole us bumping into each
other and me feeling like it's fate it's
meant to be oh my gosh
um fast forward I was 19 I'd moved up my
parents I was living on my own I was
living a great life I was very happy
um and again I moved I moved into a
place and on my first day of living
there I've gone to the like the local
shop and he's just there and he's like
this is the pub the pub next door is
where he like cashed his checks after
work and stuff so again this just fueled
this we're meant to be this is the
universe this is God bringing us
together
um so we got back together when I was
19. we had our daughter when I was 21 uh
our son when I was 20 uh 22 and we had a
10-year relationship wow we separated
when I was 30 when I was 30. he's only
two years older than me so he was 32.
um and it was very in the beginning
stages it was very I wouldn't say it was
very toxic but I didn't see him for what
he was I was just in this bubble of I
love him and he's who I'm going to be
with forever would you say he was a bad
boy or a nice guy I would say that I
believed he was a nice guy but in
hindsight he's not a very nice person
okay he's a bad like if you if you're
Declassified one he'd be a bad boy yeah
but not like your your stereotypical bad
boy like he's got Edge about him more
like you're just not a very nice person
you're actually very insecure you've got
a lot of issues in yourself you project
a lot of things and I think that was
particularly when we had our children
um we moved away from my parents so I
was quite isolated I lost quite a few of
my friends I didn't really see my family
so all of my relationships started to
take a bit of a hit for This Love that I
thought was going to be forever
um and I would say by the time by the
time I got to 29 I started to see it for
what it was and I started to see he was
quite narcissistic he was quite I would
never want to deform his character and
say he was narcissistic but from my
experience I felt like I was being
emotionally manipulated me manipulated
and things like that
um so we separated when I was 30 and it
was actually a really a bad breakup like
really really bad breakup and so we've
been we haven't been together for five
years four and a half five years and he
hates my guts we co-parent and he's a
great father I wouldn't take that away
from him my children absolutely adore
him and he adores them they see him very
regularly but he he doesn't even give me
eye contact he hates me why I don't mind
um to be honest with you I think
I think that he didn't take the time to
heal from our relationship and if I'm
being really transparent
um I checked out in like the last year
of our relationship I checked out he you
know he was doing his thing he was
unfaithful in the beginning of our
relationship
um it prompted like an open relationship
for like a year which I didn't really
want to have but because he wanted to
have it I kind of agreed with it because
I felt like that was the right thing to
do I never stepped out and did anything
but I would like tell him I was going on
a date and I'd go to like my
girlfriend's house and just chill with
her so that he thought I was going on a
date because I knew that he would be
with someone else it was really bad
really toxic this sounds very this is
very Pammy actually this is quite Grammy
so I'm curious out of everyone here what
who was anyone not on to get off on
again off again with the guy
well I would say for the 10 years we
were consistent in the first four years
we were on and off I don't know I've
never done the on and off thing so you
were you were completely on yeah I was
on and off on and off I don't know I
don't know
um because he went in jail it's a bit
yeah
do you think that women like instability
because everyone's for the most part
everyone's ex doesn't sound stable I
feel like we don't like it it's not
really a choice with them because
there's no stable man
my boyfriend is very stable
but there are a lot I'm very lucky with
mine but there are a lot that aren't so
I feel like if it was up to us it would
all be stable but
there's two of us in it and always one
is not stable you know what I mean yeah
but I mean as a young woman you have so
much Choice like there's so many men in
the friend zone
very stable but we never pick them we
don't do I don't know why we don't pick
them and it's almost like there's like I
don't know like a thrill of the ups and
downs like even with my ex I feel like
part of the reason why I was even so
attracted to him in the first place is
because like he's just unpredictable
like you know them people that you can
call them bad people but they're only
good to you it's that kind of a chat I
don't know if you kind of understand
what I'm saying uh but it's like it it
makes you feel like wow like makes you
feel special yeah I think women like a
challenge when it comes to love I think
they like to feel that they've got to
win
the guy over I felt that in my younger
days I sound like I'm really old now I'm
not I'm still I'm not old still young
but you know it was that feeling of like
feeling like in some way like when with
the ex you know when I saw him with
somebody else it's like I want to win
him back you know because I felt like I
had to prove that I was the better one
you know I think that's that you can say
that's ego or your pride but I do feel
there is a lot yeah it's literally but I
think it's attached to a sense of
worthiness that you don't feel worthy
for love just to come easy to you that
you have to work for it and I know that
I experienced that growing up with my
mum
um breaking up with my dad when I was
three and I swear to God that woman
probably only in the past few years has
got over him it's taken a long time so I
I I witnessed that my mum always sort of
pining after my dad in this roundabout
way so that's where I learned that
behavior from that feeling like love had
to be about pining for someone craving
them rather than them just coming easy
to you I feel like there's um that's one
way to look at it but from my experience
like I have had something that's like
kind of up and down stuff and I feel
like as women we when we get emotionally
attached we kind of feel like from my
experience I'm like oh you know I know
um that there might be some flaws in
this person but I've seen people change
um they can change too I know the right
way they just have to see the right way
and our relationship people change yeah
I've changed a lot and anyone can change
I think I feel like people get worse
over time actually I actually don't
think I don't know a single person
that's changed completely it depends
which way you flip the coin
you can either come out of a
relationship better or it can drain to
the point where you feel worse than
yourself it depends about obviously the
people that you are before you go there
in the first place I mean I think I hear
a lot of people that say they changed
but then I watch their relationships and
they're exactly the same I think traits
are difficult to change but behaviors
can be changed and mentality can be
changed as well because you have to like
look at the um the personality traits
and the behavior causes and then you
have to look at
um like you have emotional logic and you
have logical logic and you have to
choose which one suits um that situation
at the time it's true yeah when you say
emotional logic okay for example for
example for example I'll use the
situation with one of my friends
um we used to get into arguments because
I would explain to them you have to um
pay attention to your emotions and you
have to work through them that is
logical it's using your emotions but
it's being logical and they were like no
no I don't need to um look at my
emotions right now I have things to
focus on and so on and so forth but the
um unresolved emotions were getting in
the way of them
it sorting out what they need to sort
out because they would just um go and
lash out every so often understand that
that
um
I don't know if you look at it I was
gonna say like I kind of I feel where
you're going with it but I I disagree I
think they're logic and emotion are two
completely different things they are two
completely different things if you're
operating from a place of emotion that
is a feeling it's not thought it's a
feeling that's emotion it's emotional
intelligence though isn't there and
that's yeah well that that's not being
questioned it like the logic is logical
is what makes sense if we look at this
on paper what makes sense this is I'm
going to think this through and what is
logical A to B and emotion is just oh
this is how I feel I don't women ever
pick partners that make sense
because I think that they lead with
their emotions I think as women we we
tend to and I think that when you are
interested in somebody you you all logic
goes out of the window
sorry I just want to quickly say um
going back to your point
um maybe I did what I said wrong so yes
of course an emotion is a feeling
however you can look at that feeling and
be like is it logical to feel this way
like for instance someone might um say
something and I feel like women did this
a lot um men even actually do people do
this a lot someone will say something to
you and then you'll be like oh are you
trying to say I'm this so and so forth
because you're reacting with a feeling
like um you might feel ashamed so on and
so forth but you have to take a step
back and logically logically look is
this feeling actually
um rooted in my own insecurities
whatever whatever and then if it's
illogical to feel that feeling then
that's what I will call emotional logic
because then you've looked at that
motion with logic obviously there's um
logic that comes that's objective logic
feeling is something um personal and
therefore that's why I separated the two
kind of things so I get what I'm trying
to say you're trying to basically say
like I don't know if someone come and
knocks your drink on your lap or
something and you'll be like
exactly but if you step back and think
about it you think oh it might be an
accident yeah me like let me just leave
this person alone like so you're saying
sometimes it's about taking
responsibility for your own feelings
that it's not necessarily like
understanding where that feeling is
coming from and tracking yourself in
that sense it's not about um taking
responsibility for your own feeling per
se because sometimes the way you feel is
the other person's fault however it's
about being the bigger person to your
own feelings and be like you know what
I'm big enough that I can deal with this
without I'm projecting it outside and
therefore I'm going to go about this
situation with logic um I'm not
disregarding my own feelings I agree
with you actually I feel I feel like
your feelings don't matter I mean as
women we feel one way one day we're
about to get our period then we feel
another then then it's like we're in
even this most of us on the couch we're
in for a minute and we go back then we
leave then we go I just I feel like love
is a choice and I feel like I feel like
you're right I think that you know we
should operate with more emotion but we
we don't as women yeah I feel like um a
lot of women um a lot of people in
general I should say they do not
have a lot of organic thoughts their
thoughts are like I was saying earlier
you can make anything make sense and
there's a lot of social media input and
all these kind of things so
um a woman will be like oh you know this
is the man I want because of ABCD
reasons and then they'll get um too
deeply involved in that and then they
won't be able to realize oh this is not
actually what's good for me this is just
what I've been influenced I think that I
want but actually it doesn't really work
for me and then they kind of get stuck
in that cycle kind of thing and that's
to answer your question why don't women
never choose stable guys but then again
if love is a choice then how are we all
just like
not choosing and choosing to like love
these men you know what I mean yeah
because if you choose bad but but we
don't choose it we feel it yeah like you
you fall you can't control the things
you can't control these emotions because
you know the person is bad for you so
why would anyone go I'm gonna choose
that anyway no because you fit like you
love them and it's not a choice you
don't control it though don't you I
think sometimes we just let it get a bit
out I mean you choose who you have sex
with so yeah you know you can feel it
one way you could feel one way about a
guy but you know if you see red flag red
flag you don't have to say sex and love
us are two different things where does
it start I feel like you can't like for
example
someone for a long time you realize you
know that you love them you can't just
switch it off when you realize they're
starting to act different you can't just
like just turn it off and like yeah I
Don't Love You No More it really doesn't
work you can make a choice yeah you can
make a choice you can make a choice to
leave them but it's not going to stop
what you feel you get me like you can
still feel away like you might even miss
them because now you feel like you love
the person they've done you like this
but you've left and now you're feeling
like oh that's what makes people want to
go back as well because it's like oh
like you start to second guess like oh
did they even do this that bad was it
was it was it me was I overreacting like
it's it's not a choice in my opinion I
mean how was it how is it not a choice
if you're gonna be with someone or not
be with someone like isn't that a choice
obviously that's you how you can feel
how you feel but that's the choices you
make that's a choice but I meant love is
not a choice like you can't choose to
turn off your feelings for somebody yeah
I feel like feelings are gonna come and
go so if you're going to be married for
50 years do you think you're always
going to feel in love yeah that's what
I'm saying I think it's a choice at the
end of the day yeah but you know your
parents want to beat your brains out
sometimes right like when you're a kid
yeah but they always love you though so
one day my mum can't like tomorrow say
you know what amber Don't Love You No
More it's gone completely but sometimes
they feel like that when you're acting a
certain I do not think that they do so
you think your parents sometimes are
like Pearl I feel like sometimes they
felt like they wanted to kill me you
know but they still still love you
though they still love you but I'm
saying it was a choice my mom's
definitely wanted to come
yeah if I was to ask like with your kids
I'll turn around to you and say oh maybe
tomorrow you won't love them no more
but that's what I'm saying it's a
different type of love there's different
types of Love isn't there there's not
just one type so there's like a garpi
love that romantic love there's that I
can't think what the children but
definitely with the children it's that
unconditional love whereas with uh with
men or Partners it's it's it is
conditional to some degree but I don't
feel like you choose any of it that's
how and I feel like especially cool like
you know how we're talking about how we
were in relationships when we're younger
I feel like when you're younger you
confuse the different types of love like
you might think okay I love this person
so even if they do this to me it's not
going to stop me feeling this way so it
kind of comes off as unconditional but
obviously at that age you don't really
understand but it's just the feelings I
think sometimes I think women would have
better outcomes if her parents picked a
husband for us no yeah I do actually
yeah yeah I think that arranged
marriages have got very good success
rate not with my mom I don't know
because also sometimes my mum will buy
me like a rug for my room and I hate it
and that's just a rug I think a lot of
time we go after chemistry don't we but
that's what we're feeling with these
guys is it's the chemistry it's not
necessarily like this like you mentioned
earlier I hope you don't mind but you
know this sort of calming effect that
this person has on you I understand that
now today to be love when actually
someone is like my peace and my calm
whereas when you're younger you go after
the thrill you go after the excitement
there you know so I just think that it's
also like a hormonal response when did
that switch for you from going for the
exciting guide or the more calm peaceful
guy um yeah good question I think that
um probably 30 around 30 yeah 29 30 when
I when I when I feel pregnant at 30 yeah
I feel pregnant with a guy I was with
friends for like five years and then we
we had a family together very quickly oh
wow yeah yeah and I kind of can't help
but feel that there's a lot there's a
huge difference and I think that for us
sometimes we get them a little bit
confused there's a big difference
between love and lust and and what we
think you know that whole excitement
that thrill that oh this is so not good
for me but I just want it anyway oh who
wants me he desires me he lusts me
um yeah there's a big difference between
the two and I think when except for me
anyway at the young age that I was I I
don't know if I can leave it the first
phase of our relationship was definitely
Lusty I think I put him on a pedal stall
to some degree
um when we had the kids it was love but
I think it was more staying in a
situation for the for the wrong reasons
if that makes sense
um so now after coming out of that
relationship I was single for a long
time like five years of single four
um and I I reflect on the chaos that was
the last relationship and the war that I
went through in the end of it so now
that I'm or over the five years sort of
coming to a place where you're
comfortable with yourself you you really
love yourself you really know your worth
and what you want from a person it
changes your view on on your
relationships but you know how you're
talking about obviously lust and love
and stuff don't you think that
relationships come after last because at
the end of the day for someone need to
be attracted to you and to want to get
to know you like that is all about
physical attraction how they feel about
you in the beginning so I feel like last
kind of can in a way play interlock
because it comes up not really no one
could turn my head that I really fancy
now I don't care how hot a guy is he
couldn't turn my head now you know what
I mean like if cool you're attacking to
somebody let's say you find them
attractive whatever they start ticking
your boxes as you go one by one and then
at the end of the day you're gonna start
feeling this person you're going to
start off as a loss yeah you're gonna
start looking to trade it looks fade as
well I think historically women have
gone after looks
yeah I think so yeah no actually I think
the women now I think women actually go
after like dominance in a kind of way
like the man who's manly are kind of
thing like even if you look back in
history and stuff they'll go after the
man I don't know who's killed so many
people I don't know but they'll go after
these men that are showing their
strength you get it nobody wants a simp
so at the end of the day everybody wants
to go for a man that's showing his
manliness you have to be the best
looking guy in the world but as long as
you are coming off as a man I feel like
you get it I think with dating apps
everybody so looks focused now it was a
women included you know it's just it's
literally yes no yes I mean how can you
make a decision about your husband by
looking at one photograph on it on a
dating app you know but they're doing it
they're saying no to these guys who are
good guys good character because how
much can you tell from one picture well
you can't but they're making that
decision who do you guys think is
pickier with looks men or women men men
100 men no I think think women for sure
okay so would you would you say that
dating apps that primarily looks
yes
I've seen a lot of things about like the
captions as well or how they slide into
the videos I've never actually had like
a conversation with a load of girls and
it's about looks not really would you
would you say that when people select on
dating app it's mostly through looks I
don't really know because I've never
really been on anything well I think men
just like really love everyone and then
they Whittle down once they've got all
the matches and work out who they want
to invest time to get to know what
percent of men do you think women swipe
right on
probably 10 yeah yeah I'd think that
because obviously if you're in person
it's the same kind of thing like you get
more guys trying to approach women than
women trying to approach guys I'm not
gonna lie I've never approached a guy
like that and that's unless I was a
drunk or something and I feels for jokes
but
um I don't really do that so I feel like
if men are doing that anyway why not on
a dating app would men not be the ones
to approach the women I don't think the
men are analyzing the profiles like the
women are like what percent of the time
do you think men swipe bread and dating
apps oh I was gonna that's why I thought
the question was for girls for girls and
guys I think girls swipe on men like
five percent because we expect men to be
dominant dominant and pursue it um
pursuers but
um men swipe on all the women I think 95
because I have guy friends and some of
them swipe left so I'm just like yeah
they don't even look at that phone
yeah so so who's pickier when it comes
to looks men or women but that's that's
an unfair to say I know guys they will
not find the girl attractive and they'll
still do what they're doing if that
makes sense I feel like I feel like to
base it off a dating app is an unfair
basis because
um when it comes down to it
um men want someone
who they think is beautiful women are
more for um the protection that they can
get what the um how they can build a
future of their man so on and so forth
looks do play um a part however there's
a lot more that feed into it and a man
is going to a man okay so you don't
think on a dating app that's it's mostly
looks that's why so when we're selecting
based on looks who's pickier that's why
I said it's unfair because the dating
app is unfair because a woman is going
to look at a lot more than just looks
because for me I can only speak for
myself actually but when I'm looking at
um someone's profile whatever I'm not
even on dating ads today just to say
that sounds really bad I'm not in the
dating app for any reason just sometimes
on board but um
but um is this a hobby for you but like
but like because you know like at two
o'clock in the morning like I've done
School through Instagram whatever
whatever I'm just like I'm about to go
sleep well anyone I talk to you at 2 A.M
this is the bad thing I don't talk to
anyone I'm just like oh let me look at
the weird people are about and that's
what that's what I'm saying if I see
someone who looks weird or interesting
or something like that then I might
swipe right on them have like a small
conversation see what I can learn from
them and then carry on with my day it's
not necessarily about looks and all
these kind of things and
um I do you think women are picky about
height oh yeah I don't know yeah
would you guys date
a guy that is two inches three inches
shorter than you no no because if you're
already shorter than me what about when
I wear heels you're gonna think people
don't think you're my child I think I
have done yes and I'm quite tall I've
dated some of my height no shorter I
said not three inches sort of no no
shorter
no no shorter
um no I'm just curious out of the guys
would you guys date a girl she looked
good three inches taller than you yeah
yeah
blessing yeah he's nodding who's pickier
men or women when it comes to looks
we could do weight even women weigh more
than men
[Laughter]
no I actually have like a the thing is
with women when women are bigger
like that's based on BMI it's based on
BMI so women have like a worse BMI than
man yeah yeah but that's because we're
curvier and we've got more we've got
thighs we've got hips
but we do have like the extra weight no
one
we're fatter for our height so they yeah
like if you look at BMI of a man and BMI
of a woman women are fatter I think
women have to be picky I don't think
that I'm not saying it's a bad thing no
I'm just saying even with looks we're
pickier we have to be though because at
the end of the day man can go and and do
whatever they want of so many different
women but we have to think about our
future Offspring and all these kind of
things and I'm sorry I'm not going to
pick a man if I think he has bad
genetics if he has bad work drive if he
has bad all of these different kind of
things so I have to be picky what
percent of men do you think are sexually
active all of them no no no no no no no
80 of them 80 no no I think 65. I think
99 40 40 I think forty percent there's
there's a lot of pressure on them are
looking after themselves yeah what about
you
oh God I don't like
99.99.99 no just something very high I
don't think anything maybe 80 80
something yeah what if I told you one
out of every three men under 30 or
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year I I believe that okay in which
country you know that this country
America there's a lot of frustrated men
out there there's a lot of themselves
but also like if you consider like you
know not every guy is a 10 someone like
ever not every girl is a 10 but there
are guys who are socially awkward there
are guys that just don't have that game
there are a lot of guys that get missed
out because they don't have that look
that women are looking for or they don't
have that Alpha that women are looking
for I think and there's people who do it
for religious purpose as well what but I
promise you these guys they're not
I promise you yeah that not even people
that wonderful marriage in that I know
there's a cup I guarantee it's not 33
percent These are nice guys then as you
reckon these are the nice guys yeah they
won't cheat on you and you I mean I mean
they got no one else
but that's what I say we pick
instability right we could pick the
stable guys that aren't seeing anyone
else but we pick the guys that are
seeing like that's why you guys think
that see all the guys are sexually
active because you pick the guys that
are whatever what percent of guys do you
think are over six foot
no maybe like 30 30 percent
the guys that are over six foot that are
more active or just how many girls are
just over six foot yeah there's I mean
I'd say like I don't know like 40 50 of
men are over six foot no way for you
looking in America no but across the
board not just UK right across the board
us UK yeah I know Americans are bad
they're tall they're tall
what about what about you I said maybe
like 25 I think 25 yeah I'll go in 20 35
of 15 yeah okay fair enough okay and
these five foot two women that are
demanding a six foot plus man that is
ridiculous but it I can't like I would
get with a guy who's like still in the
five foots because I'm only five foot
five you can be five foot nine as long
as I'm in Hills and I'm not over like
five seven even is fine for you yeah but
I think everyone's allowed to have a
preference of height like yeah you can
have the preference but there's not
enough to go around
you can find one I didn't yeah I didn't
say it was a bad thing like I mean I
mean historically we needed a guy that
could protect us stay single or just or
wait for the you know the six foot
something guidance but listen there's
only 15 of these men though over six
foot and you're telling me order five
foot twos want to be taking them but is
this well a lot of short girls are the
ones that go for that actually I like to
and what percent of those guys have good
jobs
and what percent of those guys are good
looking too so it's like typically if
you select a guy he's had to meet
multiple metrics and it's a very small
percentage of men that most women are
after you guys get the Raw Deal
they really do no those guys do yeah
those are yeah those guys the other ones
they've got they've got their pick
haven't they they've got their picks
yeah those guys do but then you have one
out of three men that are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year I
love that I I'm quite survive with all
these men come on get get start a dating
site please
go look at the guy working behind the
counter oh it's true I mean there's a
million you don't really notice it but
there's a million men that like we just
like don't see they feel invisible then
these guys if they're not getting picked
for the fact that they're meeting these
metrics yeah
um I mean you've heard like six foot six
figures six six pack I don't think
there's many what percentage many got a
six-pack not many I also got dad boards
even when they're not dads but there's
like a thing which a lot of girls like
Dad wants yeah have you heard that but
what matter
that's the question
when you say mum board what do you mean
like the oh the one that's had a baby
yeah you know I've had three I mean
thankfully I'm not too in a state but
honestly like you know women have had
children men almost expect us to look
like we've never had children literally
you know I don't think they expect that
a lot of them do oh they do and they
want you to keep in shape regardless if
you had children I think that that's a
pressure that we put on ourselves to do
that I think there are a lot that don't
expect that actually or I just know some
really kind men and really good men I
feel like guys expect you to gain like
10 20 pounds what I don't think they
expect is for you to blow up like a
balloon and look like an entirely
different person yeah sure yeah know I
think most guys are forgiving 10 20
pounds but it's just like when you look
like a completely different person yeah
you know it's like after you have a baby
I've heard like that's when men are most
likely like to step out on you because
you can't have sex for a certain amount
of months after you give birth you
obviously gonna look different your
body's change like your whole body is
different so it's like if the guy is not
really like I don't know if I don't
think he's got that energy he's going to
be up all night with a baby he ain't got
energy to be doing that in those first
six weeks these men find their energies
I also think what percent of men can't
even get laid like you have to
understand it's such a small percentage
of men that even have girls come into
them like that to the point that they
can cheat it's maybe 10 15 20 like it's
hard it's hard harder than you think for
a guy to get laid I think I think that
we think it's easier but it is just the
guys that women are choosing it's easier
for women to get that side of things I'd
imagine wasn't it really women have
gotten a night out quite easy for her to
go around with her fella anyone she
wants really
it's true it's so true yeah
um okay do you guys think that
women romanticize toxic relationships oh
yes they do yeah I think you remember
what I said earlier about having someone
who's not necessarily a good person but
they are only good to you I can't like
there's a certain kind of appeal to
people like that and I feel like again
with the whole like oh I don't know you
can't do this you can't do that
sometimes it feels good to hear but
sometimes it's just a bit of a mistake
you know that sounds controlling I don't
like this song I know but it's like
obviously now I wouldn't but my younger
self would be like oh so this guy really
cares like enough to tell me ABCD if
that makes sense to you I and I'm not
trying to offend you here but I feel
like women that that like that often
don't have that good relationship with
their father so they're almost looking
for that father sort of authority figure
you know I think that's what that plays
into
oh also I feel like um social media has
a big part to play in that because I've
noticed a trend where on social media
will say oh um this is what women are
into now and then I'll look around me
and a few females around me and that's
what they're into and I've like I said
earlier I think there's a way for um a
man to be authoritative and all these
kind of things but what is portrayed on
social media and even the music and
everything
um is that a man must be um toxically
masculine and then that's why it's
romanticized is because everyone's like
oh um everyone around me is
romanticizing this so it must be the
right thing it must mean
um whatever they're saying that it means
sort of as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible